et maintenant comment on est un petit
peu en retard les dix questions comme
tous les invités à laure berthaud et
coup votre mot préféré dans quelle
langue parce qu'un art français offre à
savoir à savoir le mot que vous détestez
occuper votre drogue favorite le tabac
gallas le son le bruit que vous aimez le
silence le son le bruit que vous
détestez le silence parfois votre juron
gros mot blasphème favoris on y revient
messieurs vie à des enfants mais cette
heure la tv il ya des enfants à la tv
non non non en tout cas mon père qui
était personne très polis disant jurons
qui était la miseria la misère alors
parfois amusé à bien la misère homme ou
femme pour illustrer un nouveau billet
de banque
15 15 le métier que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire l'interviewer assez gentil ça
la plante la roue l'animal dans lequel
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
je suis incertain entre mouettes et un
chêne
oui mobilité ou l'une peut venir sur
l'eau plus je peux pas choisir le 2
alors chen chen et enfin si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire monsieur coup
pourquoi vous meinau mais tellement
souvent à la télévision
foutez moi la paix et l